[Music]
there's a man who was jailed recently
for causing a mile-long inferno with
fireworks because he was trying to
impress his girlfriend oh so i hope it
works man that's pretty cool though a
mile long everybody here is like yo it's
kind of tight that's kind of because
everybody loves fireworks that sounds
like a stupid romantic idea a guy would
think of because girls don't give a [ __ ]
about fireworks like that as as a woman
really thank you as a woman thank you
how does that if bart did that for you
how would that rate for like wow let's
see he succeeded though i think jill
would want a divorce because she'd be
like that's some simp [ __ ] bro only a
mile yeah i don't like [ __ ]
no uh can i tell you what bart actually
did here we go okay so when bart and i
first started dating i used to work at a
bank all right and this bank was in um
in koreatown and koreatown is pretty
good
so we had the the when you entered this
bank you you have to open one door and
then you're in a box and until that door
closes behind you um the front one then
opens yeah right so you're kind of in
this box and then you can go in so we're
already on high alert we have security
guard that's just
we have all that
this fool on valentine's day decides to
dress up
wig um glasses short shorts um like he
went into the [ __ ] prop room and got
like the weirdest like 70s looking
outfit he had like this like red wig on
that like swipes like a bank robber in
disguise oh my god
uh he has
flowers okay walks in i'm at my desk
and uh in a [ __ ] southern accent this
motherfucker's like
it didn't click until just now bro
he's like i do that all the time oh the
southern accent time got it okay okay
so this [ __ ] goes is a girvana
here and everyone just is like oh wait
can you say the line i probably just
screamed i was like
like that dude
like he knew where my [ __ ] was like he
knew where my stuff was um but the whole
bank just [ __ ] stops and like
everyone's just scared i'm like oh my
god
dude i thought that was romantic bro
getting your girl fired
you just got your girl fired from her
job bro power moves bro
he could have been shot we have a
[ __ ] security guard he could have
been shot dude uh but then he'd like he
he continued to talk about how it's like
valentine's and then people just started
clapping monologue yeah yeah yeah but i
was like this is
so embarrassing
so i think uh he taught that
i was scared though i was in the car
probably like brandon before a fight you
know
yeah exactly
i was like fixing your wings
[Laughter]
yes dude i have a question for you what
the [ __ ] was he thinking what was the
desired like outcome that you wanted out
of that get laid i [ __ ] take off my
underwear and we just [ __ ] right there
in the middle of me banking
you know when you're just young you
don't think as much yeah yeah i still
don't think just having an idea
i don't know 25 maybe that's pretty
romantic
it's pretty grown dude 25 you're like
you're a full adult now you kind of
think a little five you think a little
bit more yeah it was uh it was not no
wig
no southern accent
i don't think at all non-regional
dialect they made fun of me for a while
at that at that bank you should you
should have done that annually so what
did you do though you you made the
announcement you gave the flowers crazy
he just gave it to me
the security guard the old hispanic guy
give me a high five on the way up oh wow
yeah guillermo hooked you up huh did you
throw him something later that day or
what uh i don't know maybe i mean i
hooked him up i'm sure
probably you probably turned off you're
like okay so this uh
this guy actually is a i guess an artist
but um he was sent to prison after
starting this uh moreland's blaze that
ended up causing 680 000 worth of damage
where more than 100 firefighters had to
tackle this mile-long inferno you'll
remember during the summer when the
[ __ ] couple did a gender reveal like
a couple of years ago and [ __ ] burnt the
horse
that was like during cover too so like i
think that was in the lockdowns and you
could even go outside yeah remember that
ship firefighters had to stay home and
they couldn't fight it
stay in home order i really want to put
it out
there's a mandate sir
you live out there and where the fires
were no but i do remember like there was
hell of smoke in there it was crazy the
whole la was like smoggy
oh yeah because then you couldn't even
do your run that's probably just
i mean you want to run
[Laughter]
oh man but yeah i feel like every single
one of these fires is always started by
some sort of like really really small
stupid incident right whether it be like
a flicking of a cigarette to like a
wannabe like cooking a s'more or
something like that while you're s'mores
more or smaller that always happens with
the guy
i don't know
i'm not gonna
yeah guys are [ __ ] dumb i thought
that's because girls don't make fire
oh [ __ ] you took a turn you like playing
with fire geo what's the last time you
saw a girl make a fire yeah what's that
time you i've never seen a girl in the
kitchen every day no that doesn't count
outdoor outdoors or water elements
that's a
made invention
watch the person who made a stove was
actually a woman or something
who made the [ __ ] look but who made
the woman
the [ __ ] out of here i made the fire for
it
uh yeah you guys are dumb
walk to remember let's see he didn't
cause a fire just named a star after
that's all you got to do yeah name is
star after a girl that's all you have to
do that doesn't cause [ __ ] for nothing
it actually doesn't do anything how
expensive was that like six hundred and
eighty five thousand he just said i'm
talking about how much does that guy pay
for all this fireworks
you wanna know that that's the logistics
i know the damage costs what's the
initial investment fireworks aren't
cheap what's the roi on that well yeah
that's a good question though that's
like 20 grand or something right like
because the fireworks aren't cheap
because the [ __ ] doesn't disney spend
like millions every time they shoot
first
it's pretty nuts yeah but they're
showing a mile long right no it's not a
mile this show is [ __ ] sick though
it's really good that's really a million
dollars every night it's a [ __ ] ton of
money i was shocked look at how much
we're paying on the entrance better be a
[ __ ] millionaire how much does it
come look
to fireworks cost and that's how it
makes sense are boxers allowed to go on
disney
okay
or like other boxers go oh you like
disney they already have
that's on the johnny
just just clever how much you say it was
i thought it was a [ __ ] million
dollars this is forty to fifty thousand
dollars a night wow that's it
it's so freaking i thought it was a
million dollars lexus ls back in 1992
that's nothing i thought it was a lot
well i mean i just remember if you
didn't say a million 40 to 50 000 a
night i would be like wow that's a lot
not really [ __ ] bro okay that's a [ __ ]
or maybe it's like a million a year
maybe 40 g's times 365 or whatever you
have [ __ ] tinkerbell from the castle
[ __ ]
risking her life every night ziplining
that [ __ ] yeah maybe they just have like
an awesome bulk deal like discount well
they're like we'll buy from for 50 years
yeah now i think hey have you guys been
to disneyland during covid
yeah yeah or is everyone wearing masks
and [ __ ] like the princess it was
necessarily outside not necessarily
outside yeah no one yeah they changed
the haunted mansion ghost to reflect the
deaths of that year
[Laughter]
that's really dark sorry
sorry
sorry when you're in that [ __ ] spinny
riding [ __ ] dudes are [ __ ] in a cove
in bed and stuff oh that's [ __ ] up
dude
[ __ ] man i don't even know where to go
with that yeah yeah
so like this guy he went to jail huh
this guy's
this guy got arrested yeah so what was
his point was he trying to like propose
or was it just for art or
apparently he's an artist apparently he
created this um contraption where uh
it's a 3d artist sparked um by
experimenting with a device he created
for letting fireworks off remotely uh
this was in april of this past year and
he just got convicted for it
just trying to impress his girlfriend
with a new fireworks toy he had to start
with a mile long though he couldn't go
shorter maybe that went and it went nuts
i think the fire went into a mile long
inferno but the firework was probably
like you know right there i thought a
mile long
inferno okay so that happens to you guys
bart you can't answer um how do you guys
put this [ __ ] out
a mile you want to pee on it for sure
you mean like a small one
because how does it [ __ ] get so crazy
so fast it's because of where they're
doing it right if you're in like
the moorlands yeah and it's just all
[ __ ] flammable material true it could
have been a windy day i get it if i have
brandon skills i start [ __ ] beating
the [ __ ]
you know that is the correct thing
you're supposed to do punch over the
fire so it goes
yeah like a candle and [ __ ] [ __ ] last
airbender yeah you know it's just fire
bend that [ __ ] in another way
ran again fire banner bro you do some
crazy [ __ ] like that in your training
where it's like not like typical like
bag punching but you gotta like punch
out candles and [ __ ] like that you know
from like a mile away big slabs of meat
you grab fish out of the water with the
blindfolds you know this is really dumb
this is really dumb but really serious
um when i when i was like practicing
like hitting for like popping back in
the day
uh i had this thing where i was like
maybe this would be cool
after i would shower i would try to like
dry off with just hits instead of using
a towel get the [ __ ] were you able to
rush it off whack yourself
never went just butt naked just being
like dude if i can get good at drying
myself maybe really it's like the last
dragon kid that pops his way out of the
ropes
remember that he's like a kid he's like
kidnapped and he just [ __ ] gets out
of it like
it's like there's no practical use for
dance let's face it stupid dog he's all
kidnapped
[Music]
you